أنا على وشك الدخول إلى منطقة نبات القراص عندما
يتعلق الأمر بفيديو جيمبي جيمبي، يمكنني أن
أخبرك كواحدة من أكثر
التجارب المؤلمة التي مررت بها، وهذا
ليس شيئًا قد ترغب في
تجربته على الإطلاق
[موسيقى]
معك.  الأمر على هذا النحو،
تجربتي مع
نبات الأعرج بدأت ببساطة بوضع الورقة
بلطف على ساعدي، أعني أننا
نتحدث عن لف الورقة حرفيًا
على
ذراعي، حسنًا، يا إلهي، هذا سيء جدًا،
سريع جدًا، يا إلهي جدًا، و
ثانيًا، تأتي الثلاثية وهي
نباتات القراص التي تشكل
الجانب السفلي والعلوي من الورقة،
يكاد يكون من المستحيل رؤيتها بالعين البشرية،
فهي تقريبًا مثل شظايا
الألياف الزجاجية بمجرد دخولها إلى
جلدك  ينقطع الطرف ويبدأون
في تخفيف
سم عصبي قوي للغاية، والآن لا
يعرف العلماء تمامًا ما هي عناصر هذا
السم التي تجعلهم يواجهون مثل هذا اللقاء المؤلم
ولكن التأثير
فوري تمامًا، لقد كنت أشعر بالألم لمدة تقرب
من 30 ساعة و24 ساعة  من
الألم المبرح جدًا قبل أن
يبدأ أخيرًا في الهدوء قليلاً، ثم كان
لدي رد فعل على وجود نبات القراص
تحت بشرتي لمدة أربعة
أشهر تقريبًا بعد حقيقة أنني سأعاني من
توهجات عشوائية حيث تبدأ ذراعي في
الحرق أو الحكة الشديدة  أو يتحول إلى اللون
الأحمر، لذا مع أخذ ذلك في الاعتبار، نصيحتي لأي
شخص يخرج إلى
البرية أن يكون على دراية بالأنواع النباتية
والحيوانية المختلفة الموجودة ثم
يكون على دراية بكيفية تجنبها بشكل صحيح
إذا انتهى بك الأمر إلى منطقة
حيث  يمكنك أن تجد نفسك في أسوأ
السيناريوهات، لذا
[موسيقى]
غير مريحة